Hi Dr. Cutters, do you have experience in how to treat non melanoma skin cancers?
My husband and I both have skin cancer issues of different parts of our bodies, such as
face, scalp, legs, arms, backs, and shoulders.
We often use essential oils, caster oil, lukewarm solution, which is an iodide, heavy-waste
light, eggplant cream, b-17 cream. Are you feeling with using mentally blue with red light therapy?
And with the right machine help, we have one that's different to the 165 model. It's not a true
right machine. But I have not tried it yet for skin cancer. Any idea if this would possibly help?
Any recommendation of supplements. We had some experience with getting some of the skin cancers
burned out or cut. We prefer to do something not invasive at home treatment. Thank you
for your Dr. Cutters. Long question, okay. So there's three main types of skin cancer. Melanova
is the most serious that can be metastasized, that can be deadly. Melanova is it something that
necessarily want to play with you, want to make sure you get that looked at by a professional.
I've also got a big fan of getting Melanova cut out, still treated it, topically,
seems to be the best method. So it will help prevent metastasis. The other two types are basal cell
and squamous cell. So obviously, I'm just observing 99% chance of what we're talking about with this
question is squamous cell. So squamous cell is, or excuse me, basal cell. Squamous cell can be
just as dangerous and just as deadly. And typically you're not going to get all these spots all over
your body. Where you're going to get all the spots all over your body is with basal cell. Now some people
so to have the husband and wife both have multiple basal cell cancers is concerning a little bit.
Because some people can genetically be more predisposed to having more basal cell cancers.
What are the cause of basal cell cancers? So a lot of times you'll see in the literature that
the sun is blamed for skin cancer in general. That is only partially true. Where the sun comes
into play is if you're getting your skin burns on a regular basis, meaning let's say you live or
you travel to Florida and you spend your days out in the sun all the time, you're getting really
very, very tired. You can be getting these microbirds to your skin. And those any danger to the skin
where you're killing skin cells, you can actually damage some cells. So you're not actually killing
them. You're damaging them. That could damage the DNA and cause rapid replication into a basal
cell. So that could cause a squamous cell that could cause a melanoma. So it's burning damage skin.
So it's not sun that causes skin cancer, but it's being getting burns, sun burns. So the sun can
cause it if you're allowing yourself to get burns. Also when a person is using you know over the
counters, sun tan lotion, that is full of chemicals. Those are known to be cancerous causing
chemicals. So I'm not favorite of those. Make sure you use a natural, a sun protective if you're
out of the sun and you have issues with basal cell. But my concern is that you two people in the
family that are not genetically related, a husband and wife that are not genetically related.
They're both getting you know numerous basal cell tubers. First of all, my first question would be do
you know beyond the shadow of doubt that these are basal cell tubers because you could have skin
discolorations that are not basal cell cancers. So a basal cell cancer, you can google what a picture
would look like. Typically it's going to be a little shiny. It's fairly easy to diagnose a
basal cell versus a possible squabous cell or melanoma looks very different. So if you've said
you know I've been to a dermatologist, they've diagnosed this as basal cell. The ones we've had
cut off, we've had pathology reports and they're basal cell. If you're getting multiple basal cell
cancers from two people in the family that are not genetically related, my concern would be other
things that you're exposed to. Because you know again causes of skin cancer can be burns, skin
burns but also causes skin cancer can have an inside out cause to them too. So are there you know
is it a water source that both people in the family that are exposed to? Are you exposed to heavy
metals? Are you exposed to mycotoxins? Getting some of those tests done would be wise. You know instead of
just constantly treating the cancer, you're digging to the reason why that this might be occurring
and figuring that out might be of help to you. So I would suggest that you investigate that.
Short of that, what are some other alternative treatments for basal cell? I think you labeled
most of them here. These are things that we have done in the past, you could put castor oil,
we have not done lugal solution, which is an iodine, but that is a possibility. The egg plant cream
is a is a topical cream, but I think you could still buy an Amazon. I think it's made in Australia
or something like that. I've played with that a little bit in the past. B-17 cream, we sell that,
that's a good product that can be beneficial. Using, I've had people use essential oils, especially
oregano oil on it, basal cells and that has helped with a number of people. We have a curcumin cream
for our patients, which is just a cream with tumor in it. Then I think we do some blood-rooted,
and I remember what else we have in that curcumin cream. We mix that up for patients that they've done
that on basal cell tumors. To have them surgically excised does not cause any negative effects,
because basal cell typically is not going to be castorized, it's not you're not going to have to worry
about a systemic basal cell cancer. I don't have the issues with that. Of course, it doesn't want to
have them surgically excise. Of course, you got them on your face and things like that. It's not always
pleasant. The ore appropriate as far as not leaving scars is with surgery goes. If you can do a topical
solution out of the better. Again, my big thing would be digging to the reason why and doing some
investigation through maybe some running some labs where the microtox tests run, glyphosate tests
on each one of you. Those would be common causes, common pictures run, heavy metal tests, though
they're not the greatest. It's not the easiest thing to test, not as accurate as some of the other
things. Just to look at see if there's a familial cause. So remember, there can be a hereditary
issue in a person's health, and then there can be a familial issue. Everybody in the family
is sick. Well, is everybody in the family sick because of your genes? Well, most likely not.
But is everybody in your family sick because you're all drinking the same water, you're all eating the same
food, you're all living in the same moldy house, you know, it's familial issues that are causing your
problems, meaning exposure to the same poisons, toxins, foods, whatever it is. So you want to investigate
that in a little bit.